patrick's in tulsa oklahoma hi patrick
how are you
hey mr ramsay thanks for taking the time
to talk to me today sure what's up so
my question um fundamentally is
i finished your total money makeover
book my mother wants me to have a credit
card
i do not want to have one i don't want
to
uh 28 soon to be 28. so
background information that's sweet that
you're what your mommy wants but who
gives a real
right right so background background my
mommy wants me to buy a red car
too but i'm 28 and i'll freaking buy a
blue car
okay so i just finished medical school
i'm going to start residency here in a
little bit
i have 158 000 of debts
i haven't had a regular income based
job i've been able to pay off my
undergrad loans
but now i'm just with med school student
loans and my parents have been gracious
enough
to put me up and basically pay for all
my costs of living
while i handle tuition so i want to be
able to
answer my mom respectfully other than
hey i'm 28 it's my life
thanks for helping me through but i'm
not gonna do that
yeah um you know all you have to do is
turn up the respect
one quarter of a notch to what you just
said and you'll be respectful
uh because she's out of line
she's out of line yeah i've got a 30
year old i would no more tell him
nothing fly the moon
you know and i'm freaking dave ramsey i
mean really
so um you know so that that's just
that's that's a boundary violation and
uh and so uh but anyway we want to be
mean to her they're being kind to you
they've been good to you and
we want to be loving and and gentle that
that's not i'm not trying to be
sarcastic and mean
but so the answer is mom i've been
reading through this
and uh this new material and i've become
convinced that our debt-based way of
doing things in america is a bad plan
and so i'm just really scared about
these student loans that we're going
into here
and one of my first goals is going to
get rid of those and i'm swearing off a
debt
i'm not going to go anywhere near debt
and so i've got a debit card
it'll do everything a credit card will
do except go into debt and i'm not going
into debt mom
and you ought to really be proud of me
for that because it means you raised me
well
and uh that's it nice ton of discussion
yeah
and if she can't put it down and she
won't um
then that's on her at that point that's
not on you